I'm Dani Shapira I'm the senior director
of automotive at Nvidia Nvidia is a
technology company that's developed a
lot of different computing platforms
specifically we've developed an AI
supercomputer for self-driving vehicles
where the cars shuttles trucks or any
kinds of other vehicles that will soon
see on our roads and maybe even in the
skies above us so Nvidia is not making
cars but NVIDIA has its own fleet of
self-driving test vehicles and we've
dubbed it bb-8 as a robotic advanced
robotic vehicle and we're testing those
here on the streets in California out of
New Jersey in Germany as well well we've
been working with the auto industry for
almost two decades now in fact every car
truck plane or other mode of
transportation and even consumer goods
are designed on Nvidia graphics hardware
and software systems about a decade ago
we started bringing our technology into
the car we started working on
infotainment systems and digital
cockpits and head-up displays more
recently though our technology because
of the role we're playing in artificial
intelligence is being used for
self-driving vehicles so instead of us
generating information out in the form
of pixels on displays we're also now
processing information coming in so
radar lidar camera information all comes
in to the Nvidia system and we're using
artificial intelligence now to make
sense of it now we have a specific
product just for vehicles and it's
called drive px
it's an AI supercomputer that has the
power of over 150 MacBook Pros all in a
very small form-factor about the size of
a license plate essentially all the
inputs come in to the drive PX from
cameras from sensors like radar and
lidar and ultrasonic all generating data
so our process there has to take all
this information
and make sense of it basically identify
what's another vehicle
what's a pedestrian what's a crosswalk
what's a sign and all this happens
within a fraction of a second we have
cameras generating 30 frames every
second we have to analyze those frames
and understand a full 360 environment
around the vehicle the GPU or graphics
processing unit was invented by Nvidia
in 1999 this is a massively parallel
processor and it's different from a CPU
or central processing unit that you find
in your PC you've probably heard a CPU
described as a dual core or quad core
and so essentially that means there's
two lanes or maybe four lanes of
information that will flow through that
CPU at once the GPU on the other hand
has now over 5,000 cores so imagine if
this was a highway instead of a two-lane
highway or four-lane highway we now have
5,000 lanes so a lot of traffic a lot of
information can go through that
processor simultaneously and then we're
able to bring all that computational
horsepower down into the car in the
drive px do the process all the sensor
data in real time
drei px - is one of several products
from Nvidia that are all using deep
learning so we have the system for the
car but other people who are developing
can develop on a PC you can use deep
learning in the cloud or our embedded
device called Jetson if you're a
hobbyist or maker the benefit of this
unified architecture is again you
develop on one platform and you can
deploy it on any platform and so I think
that's the challenge today is for
students and now the industry to develop
new algorithms new deep neural networks
and leverage AI to build a complete
self-driving car system that is specific
to the vehicle
given the types of jobs out in the
marketplace today and the lack of talent
I think there's a lot of opportunity for
anyone just getting started who can take
courses to understand the fundamentals
of computing today and now there's a
whole number of things that are unique
to the self-driving challenge so
understanding that the complexity of
what happens throughout the computing
pipeline of developing a self-driving
car will be essential to getting a job
in this industry
you